Well, welcome everybody to another zoom call. A lot of questions tonight. So we will get started. Remember you can chat in your questions as well.
Your questions feel free to chat those questions in.
Always best to ask them through the member site and the blue box at the bottom of the member site. It's always best to ask them that way.
And you'll know that they'll get in. Always go to your member site too. That's where you're going to see any announcements, any changes, any things that you need to see should be out of the member site.
Any updates that we have to to life in general that we have going on with us will be on the member site. So go to that with the announcements.
If you did, you'll see that there's now a direct link to the zoom call.
And for the last several weeks, we've had the cheek swab request form there as well. So please use that and also please help us out by paying for your cheek swab online as well.
It just saves from having to have any sudden to build out.
Let's get going with the questions.
First one, when I read the right manual, it says download or install the latest frequency updates. These will keep your machine running cool and a frequency peak efficiency.
How do I do this?
Okay, so make sure that you have your computer in airplane mode all the time. So always, always have your computer in airplane mode.
The reason is is we don't want you to do airplane mode. And the reason is is we don't want you to do we don't want you to be doing any Windows updates.
So if anything pops up on your computer, hey, you need your Windows update. Do not do the Windows update.
And all it's going to do is update a whole bunch of malware and garbageware on your computer so they can try to sell you different programs and different things do not do the Windows update.
Should you do a rife update? Yes, you can do a rife update really maybe once a quarter run the rife update. If you don't run other rife programs other than what I created, you literally never have to run the rife update.
So my computer, I only run the rife update about once a year. So, but if you're running a lot of other programs and you're interested in maybe some like
you know, COVID programs, the newer programs that are out or something like that are a new flu program. Well, then you need to run the update.
The instructions on how to run that update are on the on the member site on the rife section of the member site. However, it's super easy.
If you're going to run a rife update, you have to connect the computer to the internet. So you have to turn off the airplane mode and turn on Wi-Fi.
So you're only going to do it just to run the rife updates. So you have to turn on Wi-Fi, turn off airplane mode. And then in any program, in any of the rife programs, you'll see on the upper right hand,
the bar, it'll say update frequencies. Just click that. You'll literally take two minutes to update your frequencies dependent upon your internet speed. And it'll say all done.
Well, then put your computer back in airplane mode again, and you're done. So there you just updated the frequencies and will not change your program that I wrote for you. So don't worry about that.
Do you recommend that I turn my machine on at nine o'clock and turn it off after the program finishes before I go to work? No, you could just let it time out.
Just turn it on when you go to bed, and you're going to be utilizing it. And then just you can let it time out many times I never turned it off.
There's times that I get up and I like the switch and just turn the toggle off on the machine that will stop it right there. You certainly can do that too.
Where can I purchase the maryatic acid to clean my eye and pro wave any hardware store, you can buy that at any hardware store, just go and ask for the rearyatic acid any big box store will have that too.
What is the terminal matrix heater and tube and would I need that for my treatment of brass cancer? No, you don't need that.
The heater is is a heater and other apparatus that rife sells to heat the iron pro wave water.
If you're in a really cold environment and your feet get really cold really quick and you're doing an hour long program and the water gets too cold for you.
That would be the only reason why you would use the heater to keep the water warm.
Another practitioner is recommending mistletoe. I am already taking about 29 other supplements is this necessary with everything I'm on.
Just did a cheek swab a couple of weeks ago financially it is going to be a lot.
So mistletoe is so if they're asking you to take a mistletoe supplement and oral mistletoe.
I would not do that at all. That is not going to be a big benefit at all for you if they're asking you to do mistletoe injectables or mistletoe IV.
I would ask them why they're asking you to do that. Let's say if you were going to the wrong direction and you were doing well while doing mistletoe IVs or doing mistletoe injections can be another approach.
We just switched up a few things with your cheek swab. So I would just stay on that protocol. You're not going in the wrong direction. You're not looking for a completely different change of approach.
So no, I wouldn't do anything with that.
I keep getting an email from true rife saying I should update my rife machine. Is this necessary?
So the update that rife had, well, it is expired now. So that was only in the month of February. They had an update if you had an F117.
So if you had an F117 machine, which if you started with us after 2020 ish, we were the first first clinic ever to get the F122.
So everybody has the F122 that started after that. But if you started with us prior to that, you still may have an F117 machine.
Is it a good idea to upgrade that to an F1122, which is the latest model?
Well, sure. That's always great to have the latest model. Is it a stronger, more powerful machine? No, not really. Is it going to help you more? No, not really. Is it going to do a better job at getting you getting better? No, not really.
Why would I want to upgrade? The only reason to upgrade would be to you have the latest equipment. And it's going to be more serviceable down the road.
That would be the only reason why you would really want to upgrade. It's like, okay, well, then I'll know I'll have the best, the latest and greatest piece of equipment that, you know, there may be a time where they're not going to service the F117.
We've had patients that started with us 15 years ago that are still doing great that we've gotten calls from in the last several weeks, say that they sent their F117 in for repair.
And true life said, well, you really need to upgrade it to F122. So they ended up upgraded to F122. Now could they have gotten repaired if they would have pushed for it? I don't know.
True life is going through change and ownership. And so far, they've been great to work with, but, you know, I don't know if they're trying to just push people to the F122 for sake.
Easily repair and a heartier, sturdier machine with good to say these people had it for 12 15 years and their F117 was working great.
So if you have an F117, you may want to call to life and ask them about upgrading to the F122.
Or you could call us and we could help you with that too.
Okay, we did a cheek swab in December and you tested my SEACT capsules, but see my kidneys got tender when I took them. So I stopped my last cheek swab. I had asked if it's a good idea for your tea.
I didn't see I should take it or not. So if I didn't recommend that you should take it, then you don't, I'm not going to say don't take something that we test for.
So it's it's so if I didn't make that recommendation that I'm not recommending it.
Also after stopping the medications for metastatic breast cancer, Megan, and she's talking about Megan Van Zell here, who we recommend for to a lot of people who go through emotional healing.
She's the person we recommend that can help with that. So Megan Van Zell want to be checking with you to see if I should be taking mistletoe.
If so, do you know practitioner know that I did get this before your test and that didn't come out. So you don't need to do that.
Just a note, I did try this a year ago, you shots around the breast tumor and then with the rash started injections in my stomach, usually mistletoe is an injectable in your stomach.
Of your belly button was told to stop due to the rash and now after listening to your calls, this was actually a good thing. Yeah, so if you're doing mistletoe injectables, that's how you dose it.
If you're not getting a rash, and maybe they thought the rash was lasting too long, I don't know.
So I don't know the history of that, but if you're not getting inflammatory response and the skin with your mistletoe injectable, then you're not dosing it high enough.
So that's the whole purpose of mistletoe is to stimulate a TH1 response.
But is this until the right thing for everybody? Well, don't stop the right thing for everybody.
Of course it is about that. So I would not suggest you start that again right now.
All right, really need to boost my immune system after COVID or weeks ago, having stomach issues in addition to my AFIM problems, sure would be nice to feel strong again.
So how does one boost their immune system, you know, regardless of whether they have a diminished immune response from an infection.
That's a chronic infection or something else later down here. We're going to talk about this question about this person has a low immune response to via his blood test.
He's got a low absolute lymphocytes, his white blood cell count is low, his neutrophil count is low and his monocytes are high.
Now what do you do to boost your immune system in general? Well, it is immune stimulants that you're taking to boost your immune system.
So basically three quarters of what I have every single person on is an immune stimulant.
So that is the best way to boost your immune system. Now some people there's different reasons why you can have a dropped immune system because of a chronic infection can drop your immune system or because of a specific type of cancer.
There's a lymphoma and that can drop your immune system because it's affecting your white blood cells. So this is a different reason why the immune system is dropped, but still the way to treat it is with this is with the right with the lymphoma program that I created.
So running your program for this your night program during the day also would be a good thing to do. There also isn't immune boosting or immune stimulating program on the right, but really for to answer this question, I'm tying these two questions together because they're the same question, but totally different reason why the immune system is suppressed for lymphoma or leukemia.
You don't want to boost you don't really want to run the immune boosting right program. You want to run the leukemia and the lymphoma programs because that's the reason why it's diminished or suppressed for someone who has a suppressed immune system because of a chronic infection that has to do with a totally different scenario that you could run the immune boosting programs can help with that.
But also from a chemistry side, you want to run you want to be taking your immune stimulants. And then lastly, both people regardless or and both of these people that ask these two questions about a suppressed immune system and anybody else that wants to boost their immune system, you have to look at the neurology of an immune diminished immune function.
So we're all we're talking about the chemistry of a diminished immune response, which is using immune stimulators, which is 75% of what you guys are taking, then we talk about using frequencies to help boost the immune system. And that's what we chatted about different programs that you'd run to boost the immune system. And lastly, we want to talk about the neurology.
So the neurology about the immune system, what is the neurological intervention that stimulates the immune response, and that's the parasympathetics. So the parasympathetics, you know, we harp on that a lot.
We harp on that a lot because it's, I need to because it's so important, your parasympathetics controlled by your vagal nerve, Gradual nerve 10 primarily controls your detoxification, controls your relaxation, your call me response decreases your blood pressure and stimulates your immune system.
So you need to have proper parasympathetics support now go back to this page right here on any page on the member site, go to this little box right here and search sympathetic parasympathetic right sympathetic or parasympathetic.
You're going to get a blog post in a video and be talking about sympathetic parasympathetics and what to do about it. What's the main thing that you do about it is coffee enemas coffee enemas coffee enemas are a great sympathetic reducer and parasympathetic stimulator, but also you can download several PDF documents.
One is a PDF document, which you can do neurological exercises to stimulate your parasympathetics. And the other one is a PDF document neurological exercises to reduce your sympathetic, your sympathetic tone, your sympathetic are controlled by a part of the brain in the midbrain called the mesencephalon.
That's why I call the mesencephalon reducer or suppressing exercises. So look for that parasympathetics.
What are your thoughts or concerns about wearing these wearable type tracking devices such as the garment devices that track your exercise level, track your heartbeat, track your things.
Well, my first response would be probably give it off a lot of EMFs, but actually I tested some of these devices a couple years ago, and I don't know which brand it was.
But you could get a little EMF testing device, and you could test those devices. Some of them don't give off hardly any EMFs at all. So I was kind of, you know, pleasantly surprised.
I think I don't think the one that I tested was a garment. I think the person had, I can't remember what was the other device that was really popular for a long time, but it didn't really give off many EMFs.
So it was fine to use. If that's what could stimulate you to get into your steps or get into your walk eat or check your, you know, your heart rate on a regular basis, you know, it could be very beneficial.
So there are, you know, you certainly are getting a whole lot more EMFs from your cell phone.
Also regarding heat invests and heated jackets. Again, you'd have to check those devices. The negative about heated vests and heated jackets is they have a heated like a coil, and it will it may not produce a lot of EMFs, but it does produce a frequency that can.
There's been, there was a lot of research on heated blankets the same way because the heat of wire goes through the blanket or through the vest, you know, they're going back and forth and back and forth and back and forth. So it's producing like a frequency that may not be beneficial for your body.
And that's why we recommend the heating pads that are the ones that we sell, which are the are infrared heating pads, they don't have that heat coil.
So yeah, I mean, you know, again, you have to weigh this out. I mean, if you're wearing that every day, it's probably not a good thing. But if you're going to go ice fishing or something like that, and you want to heat invest, and you're going to do it, you know, once a week or something like that, I just don't think that's, you know, a major problem.
I received my histamine scavenger, but the dosage says one a day. So don't take the dosage that's on the bottle, take the dosage that I recommended, and I can't remember what it is to pull up your file, and I can email it to you again.
Is there a specific time or between meals or more than once a day. So typically with histamine scavenger. So remember last week I talked about the different histamine reducing products. So histamine scavenger is really my favorite blend of different nutrients that can reduce histamine in the tissues.
It is our best selling histamine reducing products. So people are having success with it. We have people that buy it every single month that are patients. So it's a, it's a group. I mean, people like the product.
So this is something you can take it with a meal because it's not really working in the gut, per se, and it's you're not going to have any competition with absorption with something that you eat.
So it really doesn't make any difference whether you take it with a meal or take it between meals, but like a nutrient, if you want to keep a dosage in the blood, you have to break it up during the day. If you're going to just take two a day, you take one of the morning, one of the evening, typically people take histamine scavenger taking three a day, and they're split it up as best as they can.
Because remember, everything has a half light. All these nutrients have a half light in your blood. So if you took all your supplements at seven o'clock in the morning, when you wake up, you're not going to have a whole lot circulated in your blood in the late evening.
It's a lot of that is gone and you're not getting the benefit of them. So you want to break up your supplements.
We address this with stimulating, you know, try to get your immune system up is that you just stimulate your immune system through those means and you because your immune system is suppressed because of your type of cancer.
Cancer still, you want to boost that through boosting your parasympathetics as well.
Late, let's actually went up. That's good. Hebeoglobin study at 13 red blood cell. Okay, so those are all good.
So when you see this on blood test, normal, acidic, normal, chromic, that means it's, you know, the right size and the right color and everything is good.
Otherwise, they'd have some suggestions for you.
I also have extra time during the day to run other additional life programs. I would be running just, you know, given, given this fact that your white blood cells are still low, I would just be running your cancer programs that I created. So you can run your day cancer program that I created for you.
Or you could run the night, that night program is running again.
I also started low dose now, track zone at 0.5 milligrams. We'll go up on stages, see the better night's sleep. Hopefully get up to three milligrams. Good.
Doing coffee out of us twice a week. Okay, so if you really want benefits from coffee out of us, yeah, gotta get to do it. I'm daily.
So, I know it's, don't be likes to hear that, but you want that stimulation. Do it daily. Max Gerson, his sickest patients, he would make them do five coffee animals a day, five coffee animals a day, holy cow.
And I'll make it any friends when you ask people to do that.
Next question, I was able to get a Pruduo scan. So remember we talked about the Pruduo scan. That is like if an MRI and got married to a CT scan, got married to a pet scan in the head of a baby.
So the Pruduo scan, the other huge benefit of the Pruduo scan, it does not use any contrast dies. You're not using any injectable glucose, you're not using any swallowed glucose, nothing like that.
So it is like a perfect scan. The only problem is there's only, I think, five of them in the nation right now. What is in the outs, skirts, western, some terms of Twin Cities, Minneapolis, say, Paul.
What is an Atlanta, you could look it up through new golf scan, you could look up Google it.
In the last, receive the results yesterday during the last year and a half, I've been dealing with unhealed, wound after using black salve. So it seems in the meantime that the breast tumor has grown to 8.5 centimeters.
And they found lesion scattered in my lungs and skeleton, not what I wanted to hear when I'm investigating insulin, potentiation therapy.
Is a way to do low dose chemotherapy, but you're giving a shot at insulin to this person, a period of time before dosing the chemotherapy and you're able to give a much lower dose of chemotherapy.
We've had numerous patients throughout the years do this with great success.
So there's a has of negatives to it as well. You don't get as nearly as much side effects as doing high dose regular chemotherapy, but you have to do a lot more sessions.
You have to live, you have to, you know, move to the area where you're doing it, because it's really like course of three months.
So that can be an issue for some people.
And you can still lose your hair, you can still, you know, because you're getting more doses, you're, you're getting, you know, you know, greater number of sessions.
But it's much less harsh on the body.
We give it insulin, potentiation to chemotherapy. That's about 10% of the dose. Would you recommend the same protocol for prepping for chemo? No, I wouldn't. I would not go off my, that's just me personally.
Of course, you want to talk to the clinic. Any but any clinic that's doing the insulin, potentiation, chemotherapy is very alternative minded. So they're not going to just give you this. Oh, you got to go off all your supplements.
But if they say, hey, we really would like you to go off of your antioxidants, then I would follow their recommendations and we could help you with that.
But if they say, no, you can stay on your stuff, I would stay on my stuff.
Two questions I asked before couldn't find where you answered them. Do you have a read on a good comparison of how much sugar is in a pet skin?
Like is it several cans of pop? I can't even find that number of glucose when I Google it. I know that's first time I ever heard that question.
So I don't, if somebody else does, if you could chime in, that would be great. I don't know what I can't remember any books that I read that they gave a comparison.
And then how quickly do cancers mutate and do right updates keep up?
With breast cancer, you really don't have to update your program unless you have no metastasis, which if you didn't have no metastasis before I can't remember and it'll look at your file.
And now you have metastasis, then we'll want to update your frequencies. So contact us to update your frequencies.
And if you never do, you had metastasis before. And with that by that, I mean these scattered lesions and the lungs and skeleton, even though they haven't been diagnosed as a metastasis.
If the Purdue will pick that up as a possibility, we will want to change your program and add some programming for that as well.
So if you're understanding of the use of cesium chloride for a eliminated cancer, I would encourage to use cesium potassium, a garicus vitamin D3 aspirin, coral calcium and selenium.
The use of cesium chloride is an alternative cancer treatment that I have talked about in my book.
It's not something we'd use in the clinic used two years ago. There's just too much risk. You have to really stay on top of the patient in a communicative way.
Communicate with them daily and then several times a week because it can have a side effect. Cesium can be very toxic to the body and a person can get really sick.
So we don't use cesium, we don't sell cesium. It's just there's just too much risk involved.
So there's people that you know, just like with any cancer treatment that have had great success with it.
So that would be something that you'd have to get somewhere else. Nothing wrong with using potassium. Nothing wrong with using any type of mushrooms.
Course D3, the aspirin issue that's not something I would necessarily agree with.
Coral calcium I would totally not agree with. Coral calcium comes from some belief many years ago back in the probably in the 80s or 90s.
When who was the doctor that wrote dead doctors don't lie or something like that. I can't remember when it was had a cassette tape out. He really pushed minerals.
So many things he said were correct. Except the whole issue about oral calcium. He claimed that he got this calcium from.
Some place in Japan of these people, this was a blue zone of these people lived longer because they were consuming coral calcium.
I think there's just completely wrong falsified information. Coral calcium is calcium carbonate.
But if you listen to any of my talks on minerals, you want to be eating minerals that from a plant source.
And you don't eat minerals from a soil source calcium carbonate.
There's tons of studies that show consuming calcium carbonate increases calcium deposits on the arteries in the endothelial cells.
You end up with hardening the arteries. You end up getting calcium deposited in the joint capsules causing arthritis and in the ligaments causing tendonitis.
Calcium carbonate is eating limestone. That's what limestone is. Is calcium carbonate. Coral calcium is limestone period. It's just not good for you.
Really, really poor source of calcium. I wouldn't recommend anybody consume calcium carbonate.
You take calcium from a plant source, which is going to be a double bond to an amino acid. That's what plants do.
They take calcium carbonate and they change it to calcium that has a double bond to an amino acid.
That's how you would take your any of your minerals. All your minerals should be double bonded to an amino acid. That's a keylation to an amino acid.
But you can get them in different forms. You can get magnesium glycidate. That's magnesium double bonded to a glycine, amino acid, malate, magnesium malate. You can get them in different forms.
The two companies that have the pattern on double bonded minerals to an amino acid is the tracks company TRAACS.
And I forgot the other name of the other company. I think they're actually one company now.
And all the good supplement companies buy their minerals from them. All the good supplement companies buy the minerals from them. We all the supplements that we sell are in that form.
There are some whole nutrition that just get the the minerals from the plant source itself. And that might be in the form of calcium or magnesium lactate.
Okay. Hello, Dr. Cutters. I'm wondering since I have a fib and also will the bird blood clotting disorder. If I should run the a fib rife program or one of the heart balance programs that I recently updated to my machine.
You can run the a fib program. That's in your program or run the programs that I gave you. I gave you that whole folder of heart balance programs that you should go through.
You know, every day run one of those as well. So I gave this person a flash drive with programs that I created for heart balance.
Okay. Some questions that came in my husband is on a feeding tube the last few weeks. He has not had the shakes talking about the shakes that the supplement shakes because he feels bloated.
However, to assure that he gets the turmeric. Can I place a half a scoop of the premiere fermented turmeric powder in water and place it in a feeding tube? Yes, absolutely. Yup. You can. If yes, how often my doctor, friend tested him and found his liver is opening. He is taking your liver products two times a day.
Will the two work help the liver? Yes. So there's a lot of studies that show that curcumin can be very beneficial for your liver as well. You really, you know, you really almost get overdose that giving him a couple of scoops a day would probably be appropriate.
You get into the genetics course and it wouldn't let me in. The links are different than the rest and I couldn't access those help. Okay. Well, I'll have Dustin look into that.
I don't know. You're the first person to ever say that. So I'll have Dustin look into that and see what's going on with that.
No one stays in parasympathetic mode after coffee in a month.
I don't know. I don't know that that's ever been measured. It's again, it's, it's your, you're always fluctuating between sympathetic told, you're never completely just sitting there balance parasympathetic sympathetic balance.
If you could put it on a scale, your body's always shifting in movie. That's what you're supposed to be.
While you hear a siren, your sympathetic kick in. Well, some people's sympathetic kick in when they hear a siren and they stay stuck in sympathetic mode for the rest of the day.
Because they're living in such sympathetic told with so much stress all the time, there was some research back a number of years ago that showed what a person has a sympathetic stimulation.
It was the last X about hours, but it was at a very, I think a poor quality study with not a lot of participants in it. It was, it's difficult to measure that with, you know, a serious degree of accuracy.
So, you know, I wouldn't put too much faith on that. It's about practicing parasympathetic stimulation, practicing, call me down.
You're trying to live a life that's calmer, trying to get out and grow yourself, trying to get out of nature, trying to just to put your trust in God so that you're not constantly thinking about your disease or about your problems or about yourself.
And honestly, honestly, you know, I put a beam on that a quote of mine on the member site that really with sure read in your relationship with God really is a constant battle of self against your selfishness.
We are living in a time where narcissism is growing, that is the fastest growing identity that people will never identify with, but it's true.
We are becoming a country of absolute self-centered narcissists.
And just because we have a serious disease does not give us a right to be thinking about ourselves constantly.
So, matter of fact, when we have a serious disease, I would question that God allows things in our life so that we stop thinking about ourselves constantly and we start thinking about, you know, what is the legacy we want to live, you know, leave behind.
You know, there's a little guarantee that I'm going to live till tomorrow. What do I want people to think about me? If I died tomorrow, were they going to think, oh, well, you had cancer and, you know, all he did was consumed with himself for the last three years.
Well, that's the kind of legacy I want my grandkids to think about their grandpa.
A lot of my grandkids to think, I love my grandpa. He's the best. She was the best grandpa in the world. He was always telling me stories. He was always doing stuff with me. He'd always be babysitting with me.
He'd always give me hugs and kisses. He wasn't thinking about himself all the time. He was thinking about other people.
And I'm talking to myself here because I could be so just the same way self-centered narcissistic, but we are living in that culture that's driving us that way with social media, you know, and, you know, just everything in our society.
We call me as a me as a me as a me as a me as a me as a me as a me. It's a fulfilling second Timothy chapter three, where Paul told Timothy in the last of the last days, people will be literally consumed with themselves.
They'll be lovers of themselves, lovers of money, boastful, proud, arrogant, disobedient to their parents, et cetera.
That's the age we're living in. That's exactly what's going on.
That is a sympathetic told in itself, you want to conquer your sympathetic, you need to conquer yourself and just chill out.
And you know, that has to do with your relationship with God. I just really believe that. And I may be some people are listening to this and you're not a believer.
Well, I just don't know how you go through life. You're certainly not going to go through it after life in a successful way that way.
But you, we have to be holding on to the Lord and be trusting him in all things, even in difficult time, even in stress, even in seemingly failure of our success to treat our disease.
We got to know where in his hands and our days were numbered before the foundations of the earth were set. So, all right, I'll get off my soap box there.
If I could get in, get to and afford a photo laser light therapy, would this be helpful in my case?
You know, I'm not convinced that photo biodynamic therapy is what the success of that is. I just have not heard, you know, any giant success stories.
Again, like we spoke about last week, you have to go to a place that does it correctly, which would be done in Cancun or in Tijuana.
But I have not heard, and this is just me, I just said, I have not heard, I have not heard any great success stories with that therapy yet.
Maybe my will, but I haven't yet.
Yes, I noticed with coffee and it was after my urine flow is slow and heavy. I have been a prosthetic hypertrophy in large prostate.
Are these coffee animals okay for the pH? Yes, they should be.
I also feel drained after these. Well, you feel drained because you stimulate your parasympathetics. It's calming.
It's calming you down. You should go relax and take an nap. So, that's what your parasympathetics do.
Especially, you're going to feel that way if you've just been used to living in sympathetic overdrive people were addicted dopamine. That's a sympathetic stimulation right there.
And when you, when you take that away, I mean, you can crash. So, that's actually a good sign.
It's a good sign that you're crashing. It's a good sign to you that you need to go lay down.
So, you should go lay down after your car if you had a month. Take a rest. Don't feel guilty about it. Just do that.
Share your comment on the zoom call that there's no need to update right frequencies for breast cancer last year. I'm a testicist.
That's a generality.
I did it know that you did know that and just sent in a swab for exactly that just based on the fact that my lung feels bigger instead of smaller.
There's no problem. I'll still test that. I'm just saying that if, you know, you don't think, oh, because I have a change, I need to get my right updated. That's not always a case. That's what I meant to say.
No other tests indicate progression, other than just want to compare my August MRI to other prior ultrasounds.
I got to get another MRI or other cell in the next month.
Should I just hold off on the cheek swab. The other thing I just asked to test was the driver, but I'm not up to pay.
You could certainly just bake that and we could wait on that until you get your other.
Your other test beyond some test back.
I will. I can give you a refund that we can give you a refund or we can just bake that.
I will know the next time you do a cheek swab that you paid for.
Why is there no need for more right updates with breast cancer? Well, there usually isn't.
And the reason is is because I literally in every person's breast cancer program, I put every possible breast cancer frequency.
There is in that. So the breast cancer program is really concentrated and conclusive. So that's the only thing.
Yeah, yes, there are personalized frequencies, but it's that usually doesn't change, but it can. So we just really want to look at it.
If there's a change in the cancer. So if you feel like it's gotten larger, well, then we should test for it.
Yes, like that other person, theirs has gotten larger. So we should test for it.
And certainly if it's metastasized, we should do that.
The kiss quality hormone blocker. I said not to eat pomegranate or grapefruit.
My allergic acid supplement has pomegranate extract in it. Is this contraindicators? There's totally different than a pomegranate.
That's a good question for your oncologist. Bring that supplement in and ask them if that's going to interfere.
Some times great fruit and different nutrients can interfere with a drug.
I would certainly think if you took it away from the time you're taking the drug, it wouldn't be a problem.
But you'd have to ask the your oncologist about that or your pharmacist about that.
It has been on a few, two last few days. He's been coughing up a lot of flim. He seems a slant.
He started nebulizer today. What else can he do to eliminate the flim?
Well, a lot of flim can be an increased mucus production. That's usually from.
An immune chemical called interleukin 13 and interleukin 4. Those are TH2 cytokines.
Decreasing flow is increasing your immune system. That's what you want to do.
Any good any of his immune stimulants, I know you said he's not been able to get a lot of his supplements and if you can get any of his immune stimulants and that would probably help.
Make sure that he is sitting up so he isn't just developing flim and not able to cough that up.
Also pressure on his chest stimulation on his chest like a little vibrator can be really helpful.
Like you can buy those muscle vibrators at target that are good for your your shoulders or something like that.
Putting that right on your chest can help loosen up any flim that's in there and he can get that out and cough that out.
That can be really helpful to any other questions.
Okay, we will say goodbye for tonight. No, then I'm praying for all of you guys and I think about you guys all the time, every one of you.
And I just ask you guys to continue praying for us so that we can help as many people as possible and know that God loves you more than anything.
And he's got you in the palm of his hands. He just wants you to climb up on his lap and just to snuggle with him.
So keep that picture in your mind as you go to bed tonight. That's what your Heavenly Father is like.
All right, bye bye everybody.